este anuncio de la captura de la
población de Soledad por parte de Rusia
fue hecho por la agrupación paramilitar
Wagner una Una milicia privada que ha
liderado No solamente la lucha por esta
población sino también y especialmente
por la población de bakú a pocos
kilómetros de soledad y que es una
población que se ha convertido casi en
una obsesión para los rusos y
especialmente para las fuerzas de Wagner
que llevan luchando sin ningún éxito por
tener su control en los últimos meses ni
el ejército ucraniano que no ha
confirmado que esta población de Soledad
está en control de los rusos ni siquiera
el Ministerio de defensa ruso que ha
dicho que hay que esperar la
confirmación aseguran de que esto haya
sucedido dicen que hay paracaídas que
han logrado controlar el norte y el sur
de esta población pero se conoce que
allí se sigue luchando
intensamente esta sería la primera
Victoria tal vez de llegar a suceder
para las fuerzas rusas en meses después
de que las fuerzas ucranianas han
recuperado parte o gran parte de la
región del Norte especialmente en
jarquín y la población también la
capital de gersón que era la única
capital de provincia que se encontraba
en poder de las fuerzas rusas soledad no
es una población que tenga un valor
estratégico y además tampoco
significaría que con su captura puedan
luego tomar la población de bakmut como
han dicho varios analistas militares que
aseguran que esto no significa que esta
población por la cual se lleva luchando
por meses en el don vast vaya a terminar
finalmente en poder del ejército de
Moscú